the new president got straight to work
in a partially revamped oval office
signing a series of executive orders
and actions he's expected to sign ten
more today
as part of an aggressive new effort to
control the pandemic
our senior white house and political
correspondent ed o'keefe
has the details ed good morning good
morning anthony those
executive orders are designed to expand
access to vex
to testing and to vaccination programs
across the country
and in another sign of how things are
changing this morning the new white
house chief medical advisor dr anthony
fauci
addressed the world health organization
a group the united states is set to
rejoin
his remarks came exactly one year to the
day of the first confirmed case of covet
19
in this country president biden's new
nationwide covet strategy includes
getting 100 million vaccines into the
arms of americans by the end of april
and safely reopening schools in the next
100 days
the biden administration plans to set up
vaccine centers at stadiums and
community centers and to deploy federal
personnel
to help administer shots overall mr
biden is expected to sign
10 executive orders today that among
other things require mask wearing on
planes and trains
and establish a health equity task force
focused on racial disparities
mr biden and his staff got straight to
work on day one
and i thought with the state of the
nation today is no time to wait
get to work immediately in a redecorated
oval office the new president signed 17
other executive orders and actions
mostly rolling back president trump's
signature policies
they end the so-called muslim travel ban
cancel the keystone xl pipeline permit
and halt funding for the southern border
wall the u.s will also rejoin the paris
climate accord
these are just executive actions they
are important but we're going to need
legislation for
a lot of the things we're going to do
the administration is focused on setting
a new tone
we're going to be judged whether or not
we restored the integrity and the
competency of this government
and white house press secretary jen saki
said there would be a return
to regular briefings when the president
asked me to serve in this role
we talked about the importance of
bringing truth and transparency
back to the briefing room hello kathy
president biden
also made his expectations clear to more
than a hundred new staff
during a virtual swearing-in ceremony if
you're ever working with me
and i hear you treat another colleague
with disrespect
talk down to someone i promise you i
will fire you on the spot
on the spot no if ands or buts
everybody everybody is entitled to be
treated with decency
and dignity that's been missing in a big
way
the last four years i'm going to make
mistakes when i make them
i'll acknowledge them and i'll tell you
i need your help to help me correct them
also this morning the department of
homeland security is starting a 100-day
moratorium
on deportations and ending the trump-era
policy
of requiring non-mexican asylum seekers
to stay in mexico
ahead of their court hearings and an
example of how the new president is
re-engaging the world
the white house says that his first call
to a foreign leader will be to our
neighbors to the north
he's scheduled to speak with canadian
prime minister justin trudeau
tomorrow tony all right thank you very
much